JENNY MURPHY: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to this week's session
of the Google+
Platform Office Hours.
This week, we are taking a
little bit more of an informal
approach and doing a Q&A
session, mostly focusing on
questions that you
guys ask us.
We're doing this because we've
done a lot of neat stuff in
the last couple weeks that we
think you might have some
questions about.
For example, the Hangout
apps are now in OpenID.
Here's me on here.
I'll start with introductions.
I'm Jenny Murphy.
I'm a developer programs
engineer here at Google.
And I focus on Google+ Platform,
so all the APIs that
are part of the Google+
ecosystem.
And helping me from the
production booth is Chirag,
who's going to come
over and say hi.
CHIRAG SHAH: Hello.
I'm also a developer programs
engineer working on the
Google+ API.
JENNY MURPHY: So he's primarily
making sure that you
guys can keep hearing me.
We're trying something
a little different.
So bear with us as we play
with our new gear.
And joining us from cyberspace
is someone who is indicated as
App Dev from his camera.
Would you like to say hi?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Hi there.
I'm Alan Firstenberg.
I'm the developer not affiliated
with Google.
[INAUDIBLE]
API [INAUDIBLE]
caption [INAUDIBLE].
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
Since you were nice enough to
come and join us on air, you
mentioned you had
a few questions
you'd like to ask us.
Would you like to dive in
and give us a grilling?
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Sure.
The first question I had was,
while developing this Hangout
app, [INAUDIBLE]
we would be getting warnings
about insecure content.
[INAUDIBLE].
JENNY MURPHY: This is
a great question.
All the Hangouts are
run through SSL
for the obvious reasons.
We want to keep your
conversations secure.
And this has some implications
on the application
development.
We're iframing your
application.
So most browsers get a little
bit cranky when there's
insecure content, such as an
image or a JavaScript file
that you're including that is
included over a normal HTTP
connection.
So yes, this means if you want
things to work fast, serve
your content for your Hangout
app, including all of the
JavaScript you include, any of
the Ajax calls you make, all
that kind of stuff.
Do it all over SSL if you can
at all possible because this
protects the user's content.
Because the user sees HTTPS in
the address bar-- and in
general, they're going to expect
secure communications.
So that is in line with
that expectation.
And as a result, it'll also
get rid of a lot of those
browser warning messages.
I haven't done a lot of
cross-browser testing.
But from my experience tinkering
around, things keep
working even if you're
not using SSL.
But just to make the console
usable, I switched to SSL as
soon as I could.
So SSL certificates can be
a real pain to set up.
So there's some work arounds
for this during the
development cycle.
While you're developing, you
can start by using a
sub-domain of an existing
provider that offers a wild
card SSL certificate.
And we actually have one
available that we like, App
Engine, AppSpot.
If you have domain, your
app.appspot.com, you can just
start using SSL without having
to do anything special at all.
If you would like to serve
off of your own domain--
which is what I do for a lot
of my development because I
like to play with LAMP or Ruby
or whatever sometimes--
in those cases, if you don't
have the time to set up your
own SSL certificate or you don't
want to invest the money
during your development cycle,
you can use a self signed
certificate.
And how you get that set up in
your browser depends a lot on
your operating system and which
browser you're using.
But in general, you can google
search and find out how to do
a self signed certificate on
your domain and then how to
accept it on your computer.
And then that will actually make
the warnings all settle
down during your development
cycle.
Then later when it's time for
release and your app is ready
and everything's all cool, then
you're probably going to
want to set up your own SSL
certificate just so all users
will be happy.
Cool.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
JENNY MURPHY: It would be really
cool if that supported
all the latest Badge features.
I haven't actually talked to
the Blogger team about this
yet, but I'll be looping
back with them later.
The general answer to these
kinds of situations is all the
teams are often developing stuff
and focusing on getting
features out as quickly
as possible.
This means sometimes we get
a little bit out of sync.
The Blogger team probably wanted
the badge to be pretty
stable before they started
developing their integration.
And the resizing of the
badges, a newer
feature of the badge.
And combined with this, in
general, we want to get
features out to you quickly
and as high quality as
possible, and then iterate
on them as fast as
we can after that.
So I haven't talked to them
yet, so this is just my
conjecture.
But I assume they reached a
point where it's like, we've
reached some challenge.
And it's going to be
a lot of work.
It's going to delay the release
to get badge resizing
and some of the other
features included.
So we'll start by just releasing
the badge for now
and then we'll loop back and
we'll include the other
features like the resizing.
So that's just my conjecture.
I'm not actually sure.
I'm going to have to loop back
with them and bust their chops
about this a little
bit, and [? CCC ?]
what's going on there.
But hopefully it's
coming soon.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG:
Okay, thanks.
JENNY MURPHY: You're welcome.
So do you have anything else
you wanted to chat about?
Otherwise, I'm going to go to
some of the questions people
asked over the last
couple days.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Let's go
to some of the questions.
JENNY MURPHY: Cool.
Let's go to some of these.
So reading from the stream.
So Chris Lang, who is actually
helping a lot of other people
on this [UNINTELLIGIBLE] with
blogging on the comments
thread-- thanks a
lot for that--
asked a question at the
top of the thread.
Do you have any idea why my
Google+ button still throws
errors in Chrome?
So I believe you're asking
about the +1 button.
And occasionally, it will log
an error to the console that
says that there was
insecure content
included across domain.
This is a known issue
with the +1 button.
And the +1 button automatically
adapts to
recover from this problem.
And it catches that error.
But it still works its way
out to the console log.
So it's a little bit ugly.
But it should keep
working fine.
And we're working through
solutions to this
problem right now.
So hang tight.
We're working to figure
this one out.
But for now, it should
keep working fine.
If it starts misbehaving,
let us know.
We'll take another look.
Thanks.
So the next question down the
list was from Perkin, who
mentioned that there is a
discrepancy between the +1
count of the button on his pages
and Google Analytics and
Google Webmaster Tools.
Actually, I saw that Chris,
actually, the asker of the
previous question, was working
with Perkin a lot to try and
resolve this problem.
Thanks.
We had some really good feedback
there for him.
But let's talk a little bit
about the +1 button count.
So in general in software,
whenever we have data,
especially across a big
distributed system, and we
want to be able to read it
really quickly, we have to
make a compromise.
We have to compromise between
the freshness of that data and
the speed with which
we can read it.
And at one end of the spectrum
is stuff like ATMs, which need
to be transactionally
consistent.
So the data that you see in the
ATM has to be completely
accurate at all times.
As a result, they're slow to
respond sometimes, as you may
have noticed while you're
sitting there waiting for it
to get your balance.
We couldn't have long delays
when rendering the +1 button
on your pages or you guys
would never let
us live with that.
We know you want
fast rendering.
So the +1's that occur are
what's called eventually
consistent.
It means if you have hit the +1
button and then you reload
the page, you may not see your
+1 immediately, especially if
you're reloading the page from
another account or from a
logged out account.
This is because it takes a
little bit of time for those
+1 entries to propagate
across our system.
And they propagate to
a lot of places.
They propagate to the rendering
of the +1 button.
You may notice it's a little
bit different when users
aren't logged into Google.
So it's got to propagate to
those logins as well.
And it also has to propagate
to places like Google
Analytics, for the social
actions tracking, and Google
Webmaster Tools.
Sometimes these are going to be
a little bit out of sync.
But we guarantee that they
will eventually reach
consistency.
In other words, we're not
losing your +1's.
They are in there.
And they are coming.
And they're there.
They may just not
be showing up.
Every once in a while, things
get a little bit clogged up in
those chains, and it can even
be a little bit slower.
And you mentioned that you had
spent months waiting for
things to reach consistency.
This is a sign that something
might be up.
So in your specific case, thanks
a lot for reporting it.
And you filed an issue
under Issue
Tracker, which was great.
Thank you for doing that.
Filing in our Issue Tracker or
on our forum is a great way to
let us know when you encounter
these kinds of issues.
So I've investigated and it
looked like everything was set
up properly.
Good work.
And it escalated this to some
people on our side to try and
investigate and see what's
happening with the
rendering of those.
But don't worry.
Your +1's are there.
But we'll get it worked out.
But hang tight.
Sometimes it takes a while to
work out some of these issues.
So thanks for that
good question.
So further down the thread,
Ross Jutsen
asked a great question.
I'll summarize his comment
because it was
a little bit colorful.
If a Google ID is used to log
into a partner site, such as a
newspaper site or somewhere
where there are comments, is
there an API that can return the
ID or return if the ID is
anonymous or has a real name
associated with it?
Are there or might there be
any levels of verification
with this identity?
So this is a great question.
To paraphrase what it sounds
like you're interested in
doing, is using Google+
identities
within an external website.
And this is really cool because
identity management is
a really hard problem.
Authenticating your users and
all that stuff when you build
a site is actually really
challenging to get right.
Wouldn't it be great if you
could just lean on Google?
Because we've put a lot of work
into making sure that
real people are using Google+
and creating really cool
content there, wouldn't it be
cool if you could lean on us
for all of your authorization
or-- not authorization, but
for your authentication needs?
And you can do that.
We have REST APIs that provide
access to the public fields of
people's profiles, which
includes their photo, their
name and any of the
other fields that
they've made public.
So the way this would work on
your site is you would have
people-- you'd have a login
with Google+ button.
And what it would do is it would
trigger an OAuth flow.
And what that OAuth flow does
is it would take your users,
forward them to Google and ask
them if Google can share their
identity on Google+
with your site.
Once they've authorized that,
they would be redirected back
to your site.
And then either depending on how
you implement it, either
via JavaScript in the front
end or back end stuff in
whatever language your website
is written in, you could then
pull the public profile
information for that user.
So the user knows
what's going on.
They know that they've
authorized you to see their
public fields on Google+.
And then you know who they are
on Google+, so you can verify
that they are a real
person with a real
account and real name.
And then you can allow them to
interact with your site and
create content.
And as a cool bonus, you'd then
know their name, their
profile photo and a numeric ID
that you can use to identify
that user in your system.
So it's pretty cool.
And this might be something
that might be worth
[? liveputting. ?]
I'll probably be trying to write
this up for a future
session of our Office Hours and
show you how to do this.
And let us know.
We could either do this using
JavaScript or we could do it
in the back end with Ruby
or something like that.
So if anyone wants to see that
coded and you have opinions on
how you'd like to see
it, let us know.
And I'll see what I
can put together.
So that was a great question.
That's a really cool feature of
the platform that has a lot
of potential.
So I saw a few questions in the
feed, asking about when
certain features are going
to be available.
And I picked one at random.
Bill asked, is there any update
on when the API for
retrieving a user's +1's
will be available?
And there are some other
questions you really asked
about when stuff will
be available.
So I'm going to refer back
to Vick on this one.
Vick, you're an active person
on the Google+ Platform and
Google+ as a whole, had a
fireside chat at South by
Southwest where he mentioned
that we're very deliberately
taking a cautious approach
to releasing APIs
for the Google+ Platform.
And we're doing this because we
don't want to pull the rug
out from under you if we decide
that some APIs we've
released are not compatible
with our Google+ strategy.
So we're taking a very
cautious approach.
We're discussing a
lot internally.
We're working really hard to
figure out how we're going to
do this the right way so that
everyone can write really cool
applications and so that all of
the content and activity on
Google+ stays really
high quality.
And the API, the specific API,
Read Access to +1's, is part
of that conversation.
It's definitely something we've
heard feedback about.
And it's something we're talking
about, as well as
pretty much everything
else you guys have
asked for on the thread.
So that being said, now that
I've covered our strategy
there, we don't really talk
about the future releases
because we're really focused
on making sure we get the
right product out for you so you
can do cool stuff and not
rushing something out that we're
going to have to change
in some breaking way.
So in other words, I really
can't tell you when any of
this stuff is going
to be available
because I don't know.
But hang tight.
cool stuff's coming.
For now, go play with
some Hangout apps.
They're really fun
to work with.
Cool.
So another question I saw that
got asked just before we
started broadcasting, Matthew
Gale asked, is there any way
to make my company's Google+
page a subdomain
of my primary domain?
For example, blog.mycompany.com.
This is a great way to help
people find your Google+ page.
So this is really cool.
And actually, a lot of us have
been doing this with our
personal Google+ pages for
a while using redirects.
And this is what I would
recommend you use.
Specifically, what we've been
setting up is HTTP 301, moved
permanently, redirects.
And the specific way this gets
implemented depends a whole
lot on how your domain is set
up, which web server you're
using and how it's configured,
what languages or platforms
you [INAUDIBLE].
So I'm not going to be able to
give you a very specific
answer now.
But what I can do is I actually
blogged about how to
do this for
[? mydomain.com/plussign ?]
for our personal profile pages
a few months back.
And I explained how to do it on
several major platforms. So
I will post that again.
Or I will post that
in the show notes.
And then I'll update it and
explain a little bit about how
to do it for subdomains.
So check the show notes.
I'll post a write-up.
But this will be really cool.
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG: Actually,
he clarified his question a
little bit after the show
started and indicated that
what they really wanted was to
be able to take things that
were posted to their page and
repost them on their website
or somehow have their
own stream
showing up on the website.
I know this is something you've
blogged about before.
So maybe you can comment a
little bit on that as well.
JENNY MURPHY: That's a
little bit different.
And that's also really cool.
So you can do this
with a caveat.
Only public posts can be pulled
out via the APIs for
obvious reasons.
Because if you have a private
post, you wouldn't want to be
posting that on your
public website.
It would defeat the purpose of
it being a limited audience.
So all of your public posts
on your Google+ page are
accessible via our RESTful
web services.
Those are JSON feeds that come
out, and we have a whole bunch
of client libraries.
The easiest way to do this
is probably to do it in
JavaScript.
So we don't have any widget or
anything you can drop in.
But if you wanted a little bit
of JavaScript development, you
can write something that will.
On Page Load of your external
website, blog.mydomain.com
will go to your Plus Page and
grab a few of the most recent
entries you've posted, maybe
some comments on each one, and
then manipulate them and make
them all pretty and make them
match the style of your site,
and then render them there.
And that's something that
can be done with
the public data APIs.
And this just might be a good
blog post for me to write up.
So I will.
Yeah, that's a general
explanation.
There's no code behind
it right now.
But there might be code
behind it soon.
Great question.
Thanks for catching
me up, Allen.
So let me switch on over to take
a look at the activity
because that's the list of
questions that I had from
before the show started.
Let's take a look at what you
guys have been asking since
we've started.
Scrolling on down.
So Chris asked a question I
see down here, Chris Lang,
very active today.
Thanks for all your
interaction.
And you ask, I was tracking my
Google+ and other social
buttons and used the
badge on my site.
Is there a way to track badge
adds to circles through Google
Analytics' tracking script
from the [? Dove ?] area?
Theoretically, this should
be possible.
I haven't tried to
implement it yet.
I think all the callbacks are
there from the badge so that
when people interact with the
badge, you can trigger a
social action callback
that will
register in Google Analytics.
But I've never tried to
implement this, so I
can't say for sure.
If you want to try and
play with it more--
I'll link to them in
the show notes--
go to the Badge Docs and look at
the various callbacks that
are available.
Pick the one that's most
appropriate to the kind of
behavior you'd like to track.
And then use that to trigger one
of those Google Analytics
actions, either a social
activity or there's some other
hooks in Google Analytics if I
remember right that you could
trigger from there.
And then you can track
those actions also.
So it should work.
But I haven't tried, so
I can't say for sure.
But if you try it out, let me.
I'd like to see it.
Cool.
OK.
So I don't see any other
questions in the thread unless
I missed something.
Reload.
And it looks like we're pretty
much wrapped up for today.
So it was a short session today,
but thanks for all your
great questions.
Thanks a lot for joining
us, Allen.
And thanks Chirag, from
the booth back there.
Thanks for trying to get
our audio cleaned up.
And thanks--
ALLEN FIRSTENBERG:
[UNINTELLIGIBLE PHRASE].
JENNY MURPHY: Yep.
So I'll see you all next week
in the next session of our +
Platform Office Hours
Bye, everyone.